Now there's one more error in this code, but it's tricky to catch and it's
tricky because, the JavaScript engine of most browsers won't catch it either.
Let's take a look at that for a second. Now, if you go back up to the top here,
you might notice that there's no semi-colon at the end of this ent.update
statement. Technically, JavaScript requires semi-colons here, but the
javascript engines in most browsers will actually fix this for you.
That is, JavaScript is designed so that when it encounters an error, it will
automatically insert a semicolon in an attempt to fix that error.
In this case, it would fix it just fine: the JavaScript engine would continue executing your
code as if nothing had happened. Don't rely on this though, this can get you
into problems, for example: this is a single line if statement. Let's say we
didn't bother with these braces here, and now let's say there's an error
somewhere in this code so that the JavaScript engine automatically inserted a
semicolon. Well, if it inserted a semicolon right here, then this would be
interpreted as an empty if block, so this statement below would actually not be
part of the if statement, and would get called all the time, which probably
isn't what you want to happen. Be careful about this, make sure
to add semicolons at the end of your statements.